assistant professor at university of
california irvine
and before that he was professor at
maryland where he also received award
for
being uh the most promising professor
and so on
as how was it most promising uh
professor who showed exemplary
contributions to teaching and
educational
leadership he has also received many
other accolades
and uh recognition of his work including
uh distinguished phd dissertation from
his department at ucla where he
graduated
um he got best paper award from uh
uh international conference on
information processing he sent for
sensor networks
and he was also winner of nsf a cyber
uh physical system early career
investigators competition
so there is if you look at his web web
website there is much larger list of the
recognitions but
due to the time constraints i will stop
here and i will just tell him
that he can that the floor is his and we
are all looking forward to hear
his uh presentation so thank you
thank you thank you very much for the
nice introduction and thanks for all the
organizers for uh inviting me
it is good to see a lot of familiar
faces and interact with people
during this covered quarantine so that
is
really enjoyable so today i would like
to share with you some of
our group's work on how we can train
probably correct
neural network controllers for uh
physical systems
so um i think it has been uh shown again
and again that
neural networks have been doing an
amazing job
yet they fail and when they fail in
the cyber physical systems uh domain
they fail miserably
for example here is a new uh here's some
videos from a tesla car
there is a guy who bought a new tesla
and he's excited about it he would like
to
try it himself to call the car to come
to him but it was going to hit his
friend
uh mostly here is another uh example
the tesla car didn't stop at the stop
sign and it was going to
create this accident so these are um
uh examples of near accidents but
they're actually
more tragic accidents that have been
reported
in the news that led to some
loss of uh life consequences so this is
uh one
and then people have started to talk
about um
uh this honeymoon of autonomous cars
that um we are getting away uh since uh
we are facing more reality and
even more severely here is the ceo of
the star sky robotics this is the first
uh company
that had uh autonomous tracks on the
uh on the highways and they
at 2020 they had to shut down and the
ceo have written some very nice article
about
why exactly uh the problems they faced
and why they are
getting out of market and you here are
some experts from
uh from this uh uh blog we're saying
the biggest limitation was actually uh
is not sales everyone is excited about
it
it is about safety and if you go deeper
he says that
supervised machine learning does not
live to the hype it is
does not uh able to guarantee safety so
on and so forth
so in our group we have been trying to
think about how we can
systematically design probably correct
neural networks how we can use our
background informal methods and so on to
come with
uh guarantees formal guarantees of uh
neural network controllers especially
when they are used to
uh control cyber physical systems like
robots for example
so if you look of how
training happens right now you have some
uh training
data that you either collected offline
or through an interaction like in a
reinforcement learning
setup and you have your um
you have your training algorithm and you
try to come up with the best weights
that fits this
data in some sense instead what we are
interested in
is uh given the model of the physical
system given some imprecise model of the
physical system
and given some system level
specification for example the robot
shouldn't hit an upscale kind of
specification the first step that we
would like to achieve is
just given these two pieces of
information just even before we look
into the data
can we come up with a neural network
architecture which is the number of
layers
the number of neurons and so on such
that we have a guarantee that if you
train this neural network
well you will be able to satisfy the
specification just from the knowledge of
the system
and the specification once we have a
neural network architecture that is
correct and this is something that
current state of the art what happens is
you try a certain architecture it
doesn't work you try to make it bigger
you try to make it wider
you do a lot of iterations until you
have something that works instead
in our work we'd like to get it correct
just uh once and for all
once we have the architecture we would
like to use
the model and the specification along
with the data
in order to train a neural network that
is guaranteed to satisfy
this set of specifications some
and for some uh specifications we will
be able
to do that and we can give you a formal
guarantee that the neural network will
satisfy the specifications
for some of them we will not be able to
do that so the next step will be to take
our neural network
and try to verify the neural network so
we take our neural network with the
model
and the the specifications that we
couldn't uh
guarantee during the training and we
would like to verify to find a concrete
counter example or to find
a proof that it is correct if we find a
counterexample
then the last step is we'd like to take
this counter example and try to change
the parameters of the neural network as
little as possible
such that we get rid of this kind of
example and this is what we call the
repair
again sometimes we'll be able to do that
sometimes we are not so we'll go back
to the training of the neuron so this is
the
general setup that we have been trying
to
think about uh in our group for today
i'll just focus on
this middle block out here which is
given some data given us
a model and the specification how we can
train a neural network and what can we
say about
the formal guarantees of the neural
network that we are going to train
so the setup that we have out here so we
have a discrete time system
x at time t plus 1 is equal to some
non-linear function
in x and u we have some specification
and we have some
data and we would like to train a neural
network
such that the closed loop
so if i use the neural network to
control the system and you see that the
input to the neural network is the state
of the system so this is
a state feedback setup we would like to
make sure that the closed loop satisfy
the property and here i'm
a little bit allows you with my notation
i should have said i talked about the
trajectory of the closed loop system but
just for uh simplicity i'm saying that
the f of x and
neural networks satisfy the property but
it is meant that the trajectories all
the trajectories
satisfy the property starting from a
certain initial set of states
so the core idea goes as follows so
for if you use a neural network if you
use a particularly uh
relu neural network where all the
activation units is
rectifier linear units which is the
state of the art that people have been
using
since 2010 then a regression neural
network
from an input output perspective is
nothing but
a continuous piecewise of fine function
so always whenever you have a neural
regression neural network with all the
activation units is real
the picture that we have in mind is it
is just equal to this
continuous piecewise function on the
right the different architectures
different parameters and so on will
change how many affine functions you
have and will change the the uh
the different shapes and of this
piecewise defined function
nevertheless it is just a continuous
piece of fine function
so the first step that we would like
to do forget about the neural network
for a second and let's look into our
model
and try to identify families of
piecewise affined functions
such that these families will satisfy
the property that we are interested in
the next step is to take our data let's
and use it to train a neural network of
course the neural network we will get
will not be part of the identified
family of continuous piece wise or fine
functions
that we is guaranteed to satisfy the
property but we can then do a projection
which is we will take the neural network
that we uh uh
that we trained and changed the
parameters as little as possible
such that the the resulting neural
network
is guaranteed to represent one of the
piecewise of fine functions within
the family that we identified so this
family cpwa or fee is a family of
continuous piecewise defined function
that we identified in the first step
that it is going to satisfy the property
so to fill in the gaps of this
framework we need to discuss how we can
identify
the families of continuous piecewise
functions that satisfy the specs
and how we can do the projection uh
and these two steps together will
complete our framework yes really
quickly but when you do the projection
don't you lose the classification power
of the network doesn't the network
become
bad it uh
first is a regression network it is not
a classification network
so it is a continuous input to
continuous output
um you lose something
it does not exactly fit the data that
you use for training
but it is now guaranteed to be correct
and we try to make it as small as
possible but yes
if you are talking about classification
then you can have a huge jump between
the classes
here we are talking about a regression
network so hopefully the output
change will not be that big can you
quantify that how much you're losing
uh we uh no we for this particular work
we didn't
for another line of work uh we were able
to do that but we didn't try it for this
particular line of work yet
okay thanks but uh okay but what we can
show you i mean
could it be that could it be that you
are not that
efficient for example you are not that
fast uh navigating in a labyrinth or
something like that
you still satisfy the property right so
as far as satisfying the property you
satisfy the property that you are
interested in
and i will show you that sometimes when
you train the data okay
uh using the same data you may end up
even if the data itself was safe for
example your neural network may end up
unsafe so whether you lose from the
trained
data that much or not i don't think it
is the ground cruise that we should be
comparing against
because as i said that the train date
the the train neural network itself
may be not satisfying the specification
in the first place
so the distance of that i'm not sure how
far it is significant in terms of
the specification
um so for the first step which is how we
can identify
this family so given the uh
our dynamics we are going uh to do
um a symbolic base or abstraction-based
kind of
technique so we'll start with if i have
two states x1 and x2
i will partition my state space into
abstract states
each of these uh states is going to
represent to be represented in the
graphical
model by one node so i'm going from the
continuous
state space into a discrete state space
so each
like for example the gray box i'm going
to represent it just by one node
in my graph so this will be my abstract
states in
the resulting uh finite state automata
now recall that the neural network is a
continuous piecewise a fine function
so this means the control signal is
always something of that
sort some k multiplied
by x plus some biased term
so let's take the space of uh
affine functions and i'm assuming that
it is a polytrophic space
and i'm going to partition them into
partitions
so each of these partitions will hold uh
a polytopic set
of linear matrices as gay and
a polytropic set of the biases b so i'm
partitioning the space of all
uh affine functions in two partitions p1
p2p
until pm now
i would like to complete my finite state
machine so i would like to say to ask
the question if i started
if my system started inside q1 and the
controller
was one a fine function or any affine
function within the family p1
what is going to be the uh post uh of
uh of this set of states uh we have
kalin here on the
on the cold so we are actually using
some ideas that uh was developed by
colleen uh earlier on uh reachability of
polytopic sets
that actually was uh this solution was
inspired by
this kind of ideas in his book so we
will be able to
um compute this post using this kind of
techniques and in this case for example
uh i conclude that the post of q1 and p1
is this three states q2 q3 and q4
and you can do the same for all the
other uh kind of
um of polytopic uh partitions of the
controller space
so for the people who are uh familiar
with how we go from continuous
systems into discrete uh abstraction
this is not
something not new to them it is a
classical approach except
the only change is that instead of
partitioning the
space of the input signals we are
partitioning the space of the
controller itself the controllers based
on the input space
now once we come up with this finite
state
abstraction we have our safety
specification
now we uh would like to ask what is the
family of
a fine functions that will satisfy the
specification for example
if i would like to avoid q4 then i see
the family of p2 and p3 every affine
function
out there if i switch between them as
long as
within q1 then all of them is going to
satisfy
the property and i can do the same for
all the rest of the
of the states so this is works for
safety
for uh liveness it's a little bit uh
more
you need to think about not just the
post but the free but
again this is standard tricks that can
be developed out there
at the end you for each of the abstract
states that you have you can identify
the family of or the set of fine
functions
that is guaranteed to satisfy the
property that you are interested in
and this is what i will call cpwa or fee
now for the second step which is the
projection step
it will go as follows so
for each abstract state i have uh
different families for example q1 i can
use either p2 or i can use p3
i'm going to pick one of them based on
liveness properties for example based on
some optimality criteria based on the
lipschitz constant
the maximum lectures constant within
this family which usually is related to
robustness i have some criteria
to pick one of them now i will train
one small neural network for each of the
abstract states i will call
this local neural network so for q1 i
will train a small neural network that
will just operate at q1
i'll train another one that will just
operate at q2 q3 q4 and so on
this neural networks i can train them
using offline data
like an imitation learning kind of a
setup or a with an interaction like a
reinforcement
learning setup since
these neural networks are relatively
small i can enumerate all the fine
functions that i got after the training
and then this will be my projection
which is i will try to find
the weights w hat that is as close as to
the weights of the original neural
network
such that all the enumerated affine
functions
belongs to the the the family
that i uh picked which is p star out
here
and this is a convex optimization
problem if you take
the first the width of the last layer
then you fix it and then go to the
previous
layer we'll go to the previous layer
each one of them will be a convex
optimization problem
i'm skipping some details out here but
the genera
hopefully the general idea is clear now
if we put everything together
if you have a non-linear system and you
have some safety specification
and you trained this local neural
networks that you
uh uh you projected its weights and you
after the projection you are guaranteed
that it will represent a particular
family
of piecewise refined functions now you
can aggregate all of them or you can
compose all of them to get the one big
neural network
that will operate on the whole state
space and now you can guarantee that
this whole neural network is going
when when used to control your uh system
is guaranteed to satisfy the
specification that you're interested in
this works for safety for liveness you
need some additional assumptions on the
reachability of the closed loop system
again a little bit of technicalities but
you can
be extended to liveness properties as
well
so here is uh one example so here we
have some nonlinear system
we collected uh safe data uh
we used it for uh training and here we
are going to compare
just training and neural network using
the uh
classical techniques versus the one that
we just
showed and across multiple uh
initial states across multiple
architectures of the
uh state of the art and neural network
training
and we're trying to get the best of them
although all the data we used for
training all of it was safe all of the
data was actually
uh avoiding uh the upscale and we tried
to use a dense data
and we made sure that all of them avoid
the obstacles nevertheless
the neural network training in its
current format does not guarantee that
you will
be uh collision free versus uh in our
approach you have
the guarantee that you will be collision
free
in terms of uh scalability so here is
again a few results uh
without going into through all the data
just to uh the last
row last column you see for a system of
ten states we were able to do things
around
two and a half hours which is okayish uh
for this kind of dimension
now um instead of trying to
construct the the full neural network
that is controlling the system in one
shot
instead if we can have one neural
network that is unverified
but we would like to augment it with
another neural network that is verified
such that the position of these two is
verified so think of this
other neural network as a kind of like
your control barrier function
or in the reinforcement learning setup
they call it shield or a safety filter
so we are not trying to construct the
actual barrier function but it's just
think of it as a filter
whenever you see an action that is not
safe
you project it to the closest action
that is safe otherwise you just
let it let it through we can use the
same kind of
technicalities that we presented out
here so here is just a few
examples so um here we have a a
terribly trained neural network that is
always trying to go to that lane
where there is a lot of obstacles out
there and again thanks to that
additional neural network that we added
that is designed
while uh being formally guaranteed to be
safe you see that we will always be safe
even if the original neural network the
main controller of the system is unsafe
you can do this for multiple uh uh
asians for multiple environments
i'm trying to skip a little bit because
we are out of time
and even adding this uh filters these
safety filters to the training of the
original neural network actually helps
it
from the learning point of view from the
sample complexity point of view it makes
it
converge much faster and so on
so let me stop out here so this is uh
the
general framework that we are trying to
build in
in our group we had some successes in
some areas we are still have a lot of
work to be done
in uh other uh areas but this is the
general
kind of uh framework
and uh let me stop here by thanking all
my students
i've done this work and the nsf norfolk
government for the support
okay thank you very much for the nice
talk let me
glad for everyone that's uh
we're kind of making the life uh as like
in-person aspect of this so again as
we're running out of the time i will
allow maybe one or two questions are
there some
i have a question if i may so i want to
come back to these
questions that were already asked about
the projection so could we not think of
this as an optimization problems
subject to a constraint and then one way
of handling that would be that you
alternate
between some kind of descent
and projection descent projection but
here you only project once
we we did both we try to uh
alternate uh between them um
what we found is it depends on the
quality
of the data that you are using if your
data is very safe
then the internal projections actually
don't do that much
if uh the the data that you use were
out of uh everywhere then these internal
projections actually help with
conversions
um but um yeah you can alternate between
them or do it once
at the end you need to satisfy the heart
strain of that one
another one is you while you are
training the neural network you can add
an additional regularizer
that you are asking that the fine
functions is uh the distance between the
fine functions and this
uh set is being minimized and we find
that practically this eliminates the
need of projection
but you cannot give any guarantee and
still you have to do the projection
okay i have also a question so we we use
the shield approach
in some of training with the neural
networks and what we found out is that
it is important to let the system
get penalties you know make accidents uh
to make it very
to make it efficient so when we used
only the tre the safe
kind of training you know they were not
that efficient so
so what we try to do is to to allow it
to get penalties and then we
just made sure that we corrected the
wrong actions at the end so
did you so we we we try two things one
of them is first let's
uh train the filter itself and then
train the
other neural network okay and then
another one we try to train both of them
simultaneously because you don't you
can't have only one filter
there is a lot of ways to correct the uh
the action and give a safe action
and what we found is when you co-train
both of them the performance usually is
much better
and this is part of it because there is
this signal that goes back to the
other neural network there is something
wrong happening and i need now to
update my safety filter and then update
the controller so we observed kind of a
similar behavior as well
in this kind of facet all right thank
you
are there more questions i've seen that
some people already had to
leave so uh if there are no more
questions
i would like to thank everyone uh for
staying a little bit
over the time and thanks speakers for
the really
interesting and uh great talks and i
guess i will see you all
again on um uh next monday
when we have another uh instance of this
uh synthesis workshop so
thank you very much everybody for
joining thank you thank you everyone
thank
thank you bye-bye good seeing everyone
thank you
bye thank you bye